the crown's procession to parliament
a practice with centuries of precedent
but this year deeply unprecedented the
queen absent from this royal ritual for
the first time in 59 years
these uneasy times for the royal family
and the nation
are you doing enough to help people
prime minister unease for this man too
leading the country into a cost of
living crisis
but while the actors may change the
traditions endure
black rod beckoning mps to the lords
led by two adversaries in this moment
forced to make small talk
but for this pm the challenge anything
but small faced with the biggest cost of
living crisis in decades
her majesty's government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
her majesty's government will level up
opportunity in all parts of the country
and support more people into work
but this queen's speech as much about
politics as policy this in battle pm
keen to throw some red meat to restive
backbenchers her majesty's government
will continue to seize the opportunities
of the united kingdom's departure from
the european union
to support economic growth
the program for government delivered in
one chamber and later debated in the
other the prospects for economic growth
looking slim and the chancellor's face
summing it up as the labour leader
warned over the toxic mix of inflation
and recession we are staring down the
barrel of something we haven't seen in
decades
a stagflation crisis
it is a truly shocking legacy of this
government a government of the moment
would use the great powers that it has
to tackle this head-on
bring forward an emergency budget this
pm having none of it what he said
looking to his chancellor for comfort
but finding little support the pm making
promises number 11 won't deliver we will
continue to use all our ingenuity and
compassion for as long as it takes
and my right home will offend the
chancellor and i will be saying more
about this in the days to come
but the treasury later saying no
emergency budget is to be expected for
now confusion opposition parties will
exploit
this should have been a cost of living
queen speech there was a hint in the
prime minister's speech i don't know if
you caught it he said that there was
going to be some measures brought
forward by himself and the chance in the
next few days
yet the treasury are saying they have no
idea what the prime minister is
referring to
so it'd be wonderful if at least a
minister from the front branch could
enlighten the house former prime
ministers and ministers on boris
johnson's own back benches have similar
concerns
i'd rather agree with some of the points
coming from some of the opposition
benches about the need for an emergency
budget there's certainly need to act
quickly and the prime minister i think
used the phrase deploying our fiscal
firepower well we need to deploy our
fiscal firepower now
when our constituents need it the cost
of living crisis is making life
difficult for many across the country we
have rising inflation the need to
restore public finances as we level up
across the country we should ensure that
we're a government that doesn't work
just work for certain parts of a country
but a government that truly works for
everyone
work to do with the public and work to
do with his party too this evening a
charm offensive underway with hundreds
of conservative mps invited to number
ten after a bruising set of elections
and rougher times ahead he'll need their
support to survive beth rigby sky news
westminster